que s'est-il passé on va venir sur ce
drame on aura le principal témoin de
cette tuerie dans un instant et on aura
également Aton exmembre du G qui nous
expliquera comment on traque un
terroriste lors d'un attentat comme
celui-ci et pourquoi ça a mis autant de
temps hier il sera avec nous là dans
quelques secondes juste on va revenir
l'homme dans un premier temps tiré dans
un ha d'immeuble
regardez
en la
ch merci àon d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup merci d'être là à ton et Riva
se préparer au pire faire face à la
violence ça ça va être intéressant 20h45
on est en direct avant d'avoir les
principaux témoins parce qu'on aura
trois témoins euh de l'attaque d'hier
dont le principal témoin qui sera avec
nous euh
Aton aujourd'hui euh bon le le GG on
sait tous ce que c'est vous êtes
intervenu sur plusieurs attentas vous
sur sur Charlie abdo à Martin angouel
quand les kakwashis se sont retranchés
alors comment
euh c'est quoi le dispositif pour
interpeller ce genre d'individus parce
qu'on a vu hier que la tuerie s'est
passée à 19h30 et qui on sa mis
énormément de temps pour qu'on retrouve
le le le terroriste comment ça se passe
une traque comme celle-là alors en fait
sur des loups Solitair comme ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué parce que ils
essaient justement de disparaître des
radars un petit peu avant ils vont pas
communiquer sur sur ce qu'ils vont faire
ou alors ils vont laisser une vidéo mais
vraiment au dernier dernier moment et je
crois que la vidéo c'est ce qui a permis
justement de le confronter d'avoir un
témoin qui l'a reconnu c'est ça le
lendemain mais donc la vidéo qu'il a
laissé en fait ça ça ça a causé sa perte
bah oui mais de toute façon ils savent
qu'à partir du moment où où ils ont ils
ont fait l'acte ils sont condamnés ils
veulent mourir en martyre donc ils
savaient l'issue maintenant sur ce qu'il
avait la sa vraie intention moi j'essaie
de de me projeter he de me mettre dans
sa tête même si c'est très compliqué
mais je pense que il voulait aller au
stade pour attendre la sortie des
Suédois parce qu'il voulait vraiment
viser les Suédois on va rappeler
pourquoi parce qu'il a été incarcéré en
Suède et il voulait se venger hein c'est
ça voilà ouais il voulait puis il
voulait venger aussi il y a eu des des
corants qui ont été brûlés en Suède et
pour lui voilà c'était vraiment un acte
de de de vengeance et je pense qu'il
voulait aller au stade mais au stade
donc les les personnes étaient déjà dans
dans le stade et je pense qu'il y avait
un dispositif de police parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la Suède et
la France ont été menacés il y a très
peu de temps par Al-Qaïda donc je pense
que la Belgique recevant des Suédois ont
mis un certain dispositif et lui en fait
je pense qu'il a eu une opportunité euh
par ces deux euh deux victimes qui
portaient le t-shirt de l'équipe de foot
de la Suède donc il les a identifié il
les a il il leur a tiré dessus il les a
pourchassé dans un bâtiment moi je pense
qu'ils allaient se protéger et
malheureusement ils sont tombés dans
dans un cul de sac et face à la
détermination du terroriste ils n'ont
rien pu faire alors justement vous avez
dit quelque chose d'intéressant et on
est revenu sur les causes de de de de de
cet attentat enfin pour le le le
terroriste euh donc on peut on peut
imaginer c'est une question que je vous
pose parce que ce match euh Belgique
Suède il était prévu depuis bien
longtemps qu'en fait ça n'a rien à voir
avec les événements qui se passent au
proch actuellement puisque lui il
voulait se venger contre des Suédois
donc peut-être qu'il attendait ce match
depuis longtemps et que quoi qu'il
arrive il voulait commettre un attentat
ce jour-là alors il y a oui cette
revendication là mais il y en a une
autre en fait il y a un enfant de 10 ans
qui est décédé aux États-Unis qui s'est
fait tué à coup de couteau et qui était
d'origine palestinienne et voilà et
apparemment VO c'est ce qu' l'a fait
réagir aussi donc en fait c'est des gens
qui sont assez faibles d'esprit et qui
rebondissent sur tout ce qu'il est tout
ce qui leur donne de l'émotion et et ils
nourrissent en fait une haine envers
notre société envers ce queon représente
en Europe mais dans le monde aussi quoi
c'est vraiment une autre une autre
vision du monde vous vous trouvez que
c'était un lapse de temps important
parce que c'est vrai que c'est en soit
c'est c'est c'est pas très long mais
quand vous avez euh un terroriste dans
les rues armé jusqu'au dents qui se
balade mine de rien dans une ville 10h
ou 12h c'est une éternité et c'est
extrêmement long c'est extrêmement long
pour pour nous citoyens just on se
demande pourquoi àon je vous le dis on
se demande aussi pourquoi et
heureusement le le bilan aurait pu être
beaucoup plus lourd puisque il était
dans la ville pendant une dizaine
d'heures 12hur à votre avis pourquoi le
bilan n'est pas plus grave je pense une
fois qu'il a qu'il a commis son son acte
euh ça y est il avait il avait fait ce
qu'il avait à faire d'accord euh je
reviens en 2015 les frères Kashi une
fois qu'ils ont fait Charlie Hebdo ils
auraient pu tuer des gens dans la rue
ils ne l'ont pas fait ça y est ils
avaient fait leur mission lui en fait il
voulait c'est un acte qui tue une
personne deux personnes ou plus bon il
fait ce qu'il peut c'est un c'est un
terroriste de
l'opportunité alors c'est le patron d'un
café qui l'a retrouvé comment c'est
possible
bah avec le avec la photo avec la vidé
comment qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
fait il a il a il a vu la vidéo il s'est
dit ou il a reconnu à priori il aurait
appelé donc les services de de police
qui sont arrivés sur place qui ont fait
un bouclage et à partir de là on
s'organise pour faire pour faire une
interpellation donc donc là ça prend
aussi un certain temps à savoir est-ce
qu'il est armé on essaie d'avoir du
renseignement parce qu'on se lance pas
comme ça sur une interpellation ce qu'on
appelle en milieu ouvert c'estàdire dans
dans la rue ou dans un café sur une
personne qui est armée et qui pourrait
faire une prise d'otage ou quelque chose
comme ça de très dangereux avec des
dommages collatéraux combien d'attentats
sont des jou en France chaque année à
peu près alors j'ai pas les chiffres
mais je sais que les collègues
travaillent énormément là en ce moment
en ce moment on vous avez des infos il y
en a beaucoup qui sont déjoués ou pas du
tout je sais qu'il y en a qui sont
déjoués je sais qu'il y a des menaces je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
sous surveillance que et en fait c'est
une c'est une surveillance qui est sur
Internet qui est qui est dans la dans
dans l'in dans l'infiltration et dans la
et dans le dans la poursuite en fait en
filature de certaines personnes mais ça
ça demande énormément d'effectifs c'est
extrêmement complexe donc en fait il y a
une vigilance en écoute téléphonique sur
les réseaux sociaux sur pareil les
cartes bleues quand ils utilisent pour
essayer de localiser en permanence che
les fichiers et les personnes qui sont
susceptibles de passer à l'acte pourquoi
vous avez quitté le GG parce que j'étais
blessé d'accord vous êtes blessé où je
suis blessé au cervicale j'ai une
prothèse et je suis presque s d'une
oreille d'accord donc vous c'est un gros
regret pour vous
non alors j'ai fait 15 années HE 15
années c'est long dans une carrière
quand on sait le rythme du travail du G
et et le le gilet par bal qui fait 45 kg
avec arme le casque 5 6 kg sur la tête
et qu'on enchaîne vraiment donc
psychologiquement j'étais j'étais encore
bien physiquement j'étais très fatigué
et puis non il était temps pour moi de
passer la main aussi au au plus jeunes
vous AZ écrit un livre àon etiva se
préparer au pire c'est quoi se préparer
au pire bah c'est se préparer à ce qui
au à ce que la la la violence puisse
nous tomber dessus c'est pas réservé aux
autres c'est ça peut ça peut nous tomber
dessus et je dirais pire ça peut tomber
sur nos proches parce qu'en fait nous
parfois on a tendance à à faire un dénis
de la violence on la rejette un peu on
fait un rejet mais quand il s'agit de
nos proches ou nos enfants on est on a
une vision qui est complètement
différente là on s'implique et ce livre
en fait il a pour but de de partager des
des conseils de des précautions qui
doivent devenir des actes réflexes c'est
ce que disait tout à l'heure la
porte-parole c'est chacun de se sentir
concerné d'être vigilant de lever un peu
le nez de du portable d'enlever les
écouteurs de se regarder et on peut
avoir des interactions qui peuvent être
pas pas que anxiogènees entre nous mais
bah voilà c'est moi tiens juste là ouais
voilà mais mais voilà c'est vraiment
c'est se prépare alors c'est pas c'est
pas un livre qui doit qui doit vraiment
être anxiogène et et faire peur aux gens
c'est vraiment quand on est préparé
quand on est bah que ce soit en sport
dans n'importe quel le domaine quand on
est bien préparé on est un peu plus sin
donc vraiment c'est pour se libérer un
peu la tête de certaines choses et pour
viser juste en fait pour ne pas être
dans la surprise merci à ton